bien le jeu vous excuser leur place
souffrant ce soir et dont jaked
reprenons le myriam alors si l'on veut
chercher le 2 cv parfait des halles
l'exemple même de tout ce qu'on peut
trouver hommes et socialisation
qualification
l'université internationale sur
chercheuse aux instituts d'études de
l'islam et des sociétés du monde
musulman
au moment où qualification universitaire
idéal moment où ces questions forme fond
le le principal noeud des interrogations
de l'art de l'univers géopolitique et de
la conscience de chacune de nos sociétés
et du souci de chacun d'entre nous que
tous a retenti sur notre réflexion notre
vision du monde et de surcroît dans ce
sujet central
myriam bentrad et spécialistes du centre
du centre c'est-à-dire du conflit syrien
irakien enfin l'endroit où se noue le le
plus frappant de
c'est de ce maelström qui constitue pour
notre temps alain soucy désormais lourd
nous le vivons en france mais nous ne
sommes pas les seuls à vivre en france
simplement ce qui s'est passé en france
a aujourd'hui des retentissements sur la
planète entière et notamment sur la
planète musulmane voilà pourquoi je suis
très heureux d'accueillir myriam badra
de bontin j'ai pas besoin de vous
expliquer qu'elle est très jeune pour
une qualification de cet ordre c'est une
raison de plus de l'accueillir avec
enthousiasme comme vous allez le faire
pour vos applaudissements elle va
traiter devant nous des ramifications
régionales et globales de lacan de la
conflagration localisé en irak et en
syrie
je la remercie infiniment d'être venu et
vous aussi de participer à ce débat dont
je vous rappelle qu'il est retransmise
sur internet
merci beaucoup
bonsoir merci pour votre invitation pour
la gentillesse de vos mots donc je vais
effectivement m'exprimer ce soir alors
pas seulement sur la crise irakienne et
le conflit syrien donc la situation au
moyen-orient même si je vais je vais
tout de même commencer par là parce que
vous le disiez très justement le coeur
le noeud du problème y compris dans ce
qu'on observe aujourd'hui en france et
évidemment c'est les derniers attentats
qui ont frappé notre pays
tout part effectivement de là donc je
pense qu'il est important dans un
premier temps de revenir sur cette
situation moyenne orientale et et ses
dynamiques
plus anciennes comme plus récentes et
puis j'ai serré d'ouvrir le débat
en revenant effectivement sur c'est sur
ces attentats qui viennent de nous
toucher en essayant de souligner à quel
point encore une fois le moyen-orient
est centrale dans ces questions outre
les les aspects français du débat actuel
qui sont très importants également mais
qui encore une fois sont indissociables
de la situation au moyen-orient alors je
vais revenir d'abord sur les événements
de 2014
parce que ce qui m'a frappé pour couvrir
l'irak depuis maintenant plus de dix ans
c'est l'étonnement finalement de la
communauté internationale et en
particulier des européens face à
l'offensive qui a été donné par l'état
islamique en juin sur la ville de
mossoul premier lieu commun autour de
cela le l'aspect finalement nouveau ou
ou surprenants de 7 offensifs ça n'était
pas le cas en réalité parce que les
djihadistes étaient présents depuis la
chute du régime de saddam hussein
et surtout cette offensive elle a débuté
de manière très symbolique et je
reviendrai sur cette symbolique autour
des événements et des dates parce que
c'est très important
cette offensive avait débuté en fait en
janvier dans une ville très emblématique
qui est la ville de falloudja alors j'ai
pas je suis désolé j'ai pas de carte
avec moi ce soir c'est une ville dans
l'ouest irakien dans la grande province
sunnite d'al-anbar qui est la région le
coeur en fête un dudu de la communauté
sunnite irakienne
et pourquoi cette offensive sur
falloudja était très symbolique parce
qu'elles intervenaient 10 ans
précisément après les deux sièges
militaires américains extrêmement
meurtriers qui avaient pris place dans
cette ville
qui avait laissé un goût amer aux
sunnites alors je ne reviens pas sur les
événements enfin je vais quand même
parler un peu falloudja a été une ville
au moment de la chute du régime bassiste
qui avait donc une ville sunnite très
conservatrices très religieuse et qui
avait fait le choix de l'attentisme qui
était disposé à un dialogue à l'époque
avec l'armée américaine parce que
justement les notables il est laid
l'establishment religieux voulait éviter
le bain de sang
donc des autorités de fête s'était
formée et avait entamé un dialogue avec
l'autorité à l'époque l'autorité
provisoire de la coalition qui était en
charge de l'administration de la gestion
du pays sous la tutelle de à l'époque de
l'administrateur civil américain paul
bremer pendant une durée d'un an et les
choses ont vite virer finalement au
malentendu puisque l'armée américaine à
l'époque qui avait établi son poste
d'observation sur le toit d'une école à
tirer dans une foule de manifestants qui
étaient venus réclamer la réouverture de
l'école primaire
et c'est à partir de là que le
malentendu
à falloudja et au delà s'est instauré
entre la population irakienne et cette
armée américaine un préparé avec un
appel au djihad en appelle au djihad qui
a fait le lit évidemment à l'époque de
la mouvance irakienne d'al qaïda qui
était sous la tutelle déjà à l'époque de
du jordanien abou moussab al zarkaoui
dont certains d'entre vous se
souviennent peut-être qui était lui même
présent en irak depuis 2003 dans les
régions kurdes et qui avait déjà pour
projet la conquête de l'irak sur les
ruines de ce régime bassiste qui
symbolisait déjà aux yeux des islamistes
la faillite du nationalisme arabe parce
que je le rappelle quand même aux yeux
de beaucoup
en tout cas c'était la perception dans
le monde arabe le régime de saddam
hussein s'était en quelque sorte le
dernier symbole d'un nationalisme arabe
anti impérialisme occidental contre
israël je rappelle quand même que bagdad
c'était la position maximaliste en
quelque sorte de l'opposition à israël
même plus radical que la position qu'ils
avaient été historiquement celle de
l'eau
et donc ces islamistes et bien on était
ravi à l'époque de cet effondrement du
baasisme puisque évidemment cela ouvrait
les portes à cette conquête territoriale
politique et la conquête des coeurs
alors revenons sur falloudja donc en
avril 2004 en mars 2004 4 contractuels
de la société privée blackwater vont
être enlevées dans une embuscade et tués
et leurs corps carbonisés suspendu en
haut d'un pont qui enjambe l'euphrate
qui est l'un des deux fleuves en irak
à la vue du monde entier et ses 7,7 ces
images particulièrement choquante qui
sont en fait des images très importante
parce que c'est la première fois aussi à
l'époque l'opinion publique américaine
voit la violence en fait de cette
situation irakienne de ce terrain
irakien sur lequel les troupes les
troupes américaines sont engagées le
malentendu et total l'administration
américaine va réagir de manière très
radicale et décidé que pour venger donc
on est déjà dans des logiques de
vengeance pour venger la mort de ses
quatre américains qui ont été donc
encore une fois immolé est suspendu du
haut de ce pont pour les venger ont
déclenché des opérations
particulièrement meurtrières dans la
ville de falloudja donc c'est le premier
siège qui se déroule au mois d'avril qui
va finalement conduire à une impasse
l'été sera particulièrement meurtrier
parce qu'à l'époque toute la population
irakienne
en réalité s'embrase on a aussi une
résistance chiite à l'occupant américain
qui s'organise et qui va donner lieu à
un deuxième siège le siège de nadjaf qui
est une des villes saintes chiites en
irak
à l'époque il y a encore un semblant
finalement de solidarité entre irakiens
puisque moktada al sadr qui est donc qui
le leader de cette résistance armée
chiite va prendre va faire cause commune
avec les insurgés de falloudja est le
point culminant de cette crise de 2004
c'est le second siège donc militaire
dans la ville de falloudja en novembre
qui
qui se traduit en fait par une
destruction totale de la ville alors il
ya eu un certain nombre de scandales
puisque l'armée américaine aurait usé
d'armes non conventionnelles phosphore
des armes donc à l'uranium appauvri a eu
des reportages faits sur les naissances
dans cette ville depuis avec un certain
nombre de malformations congénitales
donc bon c'est une guerre sale et
pourquoi cet épisode de 2004 il est il
et il est très symbolique parce que
l'offensive dont qui démarre en janvier
2014 dans la ville de falloudja ses dix
ans après et c'est vraiment vécu dans la
psyché des djihadistes comme le temps de
la revanche
alors pourquoi cesser c'est cet aspect
dix ans après est important parce que
c'est finalement aussi la même logique
qui anime chérif kouachi lorsqu'il part
avec son frère et bien liquider
l'ensemble de la rédaction de charlie
hebdo mais je vais revenir là dessus
donc janvier l'offensive démarre
finalement peu de médias se saisisse de
la question
alors pourquoi peu de médias aussi
français se saisissent de la question
irakienne parce que finalement nous
n'étions pas engagée militairement sur
le terrain irakien et ça explique aussi
pourquoi finalement 2005 cette filière
irakienne des buttes chaumont est passée
inaperçue
moi j'avais travaillé sur cette question
enfin j'avais suivi l'histoire mais à
l'époque finalement il ya dix ans on
s'en était peu saisis parce qu'encore
une fois on partait du principe que le
non engagement aux côtés des américains
en irak est bien de préserver finalement
des conséquences de ce conflit
pour en débattre mais je pense que
c'était une vue une
une vision de court termiste est erroné
2004 dont 2014 en juin mossoul tombe aux
mains des djihadistes et bien va créer
finalement l'effroi puisque on réalise
que derrière la prise de mossoul on a en
réalité dépend des pans entiers du
territoire qu'ils tombent aux mains de
l'état islamique entre l'irak et la
syrie alors au delà de mossoul on a des
postes frontières clés qui vont aussi
tombé aux mains de l'organisation
et tout cela dans un contexte de
pourrissement alors de pourrissement qui
est dû aux legs de l'occupation
américaine qui n'a finalement pas laissé
un pays pacifié comme sans réclamer
barack obama au moment de sa déclaration
en décembre 2011
mais un pays en proie à une crise
politique profonde
les sunnites au delà de l'insurrection
armée sont eux mêmes très divisés ont
été complètement mise en marge du
processus de transition pourquoi parce
que l'ancienne opposition irakienne qui
étaient majoritairement chiite et kurde
partant du postulat que les sunnites qui
était historiquement finalement
l'ossature de la technocratie de
l'administration irakienne et qui avait
fourni beaucoup de cadres ou partie
basse et à l'armée était finalement des
éléments perturbateurs qu'il fallait
mettre de côté pour pouvoir assurer
cette transition démocratique
donc on a une aliénation sunnite qui
s'est mise en place en fait dès 2003 qui
a été comme j'ai dis donc exacerber au
moment du sud et deux sièges unitaire de
fallouja et qui va permettre à l'époque
déjà al qaïda dont qui la branche
irakienne d'al-qaïda de prendre le
dessus sur l'ensemble des mouvements de
résistance parce que cette résistance
armée à les multiples on à d'anciens
bassiste on a des nationalistes plus ou
moins modérés on a une frange islamistes
qui ne tombe pas dans le salafisme tout
cela est très complexe mais à partir du
moment où falloudja et rasé zarqaoui et
ses acolytes vont finalement avoir le
champ libre en disant toute forme de
compromis est impossible qu'il s'agisse
d'un compromis avec les américains ou
avec encore une fois les autorités
chiites et kurdes est la seule solution
pour résoudre cette impasse sunnites
c'est la formation d'un
gouvernement proprement sunnite donc la
restauration du califat qui ne peut être
que le modèle qui permettra aux sunnites
bafouée dépossédé de reprendre le
pouvoir et de se venger donc c'est
d'ailleurs tout le sens du titre de mon
ouvrage la revanche de l'histoire parce
qu'on réalité7 cette offensive
jihadistes et ses conséquences
aujourd'hui on le voit régionales et
globales ne sont que la conséquence
d'une longue revanche qui a mûri parmi
cette mouvance jihadiste donc à partir
de 2004 2005 on a une prise en mains de
l'insurrection armée par ces jihadistes
on a une phase de mise en déroute
entre 2006 et 2008 parce qu'un certain
nombre de tribus dans les régions
sunnites ont décidé de s'allier même
indirectement aux américains contre les
djihadistes alors à l'époque ce n'est
pas du tout un réflexe patriotique il
faut casser les mythes existants c'est
une question de business parce que les
tribus avaient le contrôle de la
contrebande de pétrole depuis l'époque
de saddam hussein et le perdre la perte
par don de cette contrebande parce que
les djihadistes vont prendre le contrôle
et les tribus dont pour récupérer
finalement les fruits de cette
contrebande et puis restaurer un
semblant d'autorité vont se rapprocher
des généraux américains alors en gros
ils vont voir un général en disant bon
il faut absolument qu'on trouve un mode
de coopération qu'on chasse al qaïda
tout le monde y trouve un intérêt et les
américains dont ils vont jouer la carte
des tribus alors ça marche plus ou moins
en plus ça colle à l'époque avec le
calendrier politique qui est celui de
barack obama
l'élection présidentielle américaine est
la promesse donc électoral qui est faite
par obama à l'époque de ce désir de se
désengager du bourbier irakien et donc
les américains vont crier victoire
c'est la fameuse déclaration devant le
congrès du général petraeus
le job est fait les tribus ont repris la
main le gouvernement irakien les
intégrera dans l'appareil militaire et
sécuritaire
et puis donc on se débarrassera
finalement de ce jihad
chi chi chi à qui a risqué 20 qui
risquait finalement de compromettre tout
le processus encore une fois
transitionnelle or les choses sont plus
complexes parce que à l'époque le
premier ministre donc qui a été remplacé
à l'été chiite nouri al maliki qui est
proche de l'iran enfin qui joue sa carte
aussi personnel va refuser finalement
d'intégrer ces tribus dans les forces de
sécurité dans l'armée pour plusieurs
raisons d'une part parce que déjà à
l'époque mali qui montre bien qu'il est
dans une logique de reconstruction d'un
pouvoir autoritaire et alors il a un peu
si je peux me permettre l'expression
rouler ses parents américains qui
partait du principe que c'était une
figure politique c'est faible qui
n'auraient pas les moyens de s'imposer
qui serait obligé de composer avec les
autres factions politiques en présence
or maliki va jouer à un jeu finalement
très très très subtil il va donc
démanteler cette mouvance tribales en
arrêtant ses représentants parfois même
en lançant l'armée les réprimer parfois
il va pas il va jouer finalement le jeu
de la cooptation mai et les chiites du
parti dawa du parti islamiste donc
historique proche de l'iran donc il y a
tout un mouvement de déconstruction
finalement des faibles progrès qui avait
été réalisé par cette coopération avec
l'armée américaine qui va culminer après
le retrait des américains par une
pourchasse une véritable pourchasse
lancé par maliki contre ses opposants
contre enfin tout cas il est vraiment
dans une logique quasi sa d'amis de
perception de toute forme d'opposition
de critiques comme comme étant comme
comme menaçant son pouvoir comme quoi
l'ancienne opposition a été aussi
profondément socialiser par le système
bassiste c'est la méfiance que
permanente l'absence de dialogue donc il
se lance dans cette pourchasse qui va
toucher les frères musulmans donc la
branche modérée du sunnisme en irak et
dans le monde musulman et qui va frapper
aussi au premier plan les populations
civiles qui à partir de 2012 vont
décider de descendre dans les rues
manifesté pour demander des réformes
demandées le retour de leurs
représentants dans le champ politique
alors il ya une représentation
parlementaire des sunnites
il y à des figures suivi d'un
gouvernement mais qui ne sont pas
finalement très représentative et au
lieu d'engager un dialogue avec les
sunnites entre 2012 et 2013 maniquis se
lance dans une politique de répression
tous azimuts avec de véritables on peut
le dire massacres de populations sur
fond de d'enlisement de la crise
syrienne
c'est ces circonstances donc le retour à
l'autoritarisme de l'irak et
l'enlisement de la crise syrienne
voisines vont servir cet assaut de
l'état islamique qui démarre en réalité
en 2013 qui se prépare en 2013 et qui va
donc se réaliser en 2014
avec cette crise qui démarre en juin qui
prend finalement tout le monde de course
aux ceux qui suivaient depuis un certain
temps l'évolution sur les deux terrains
irakien et syrien et qui savait que les
choses dégénèrent est l'état islamique
c'est la succession d'al qaïda en irak
la succession pourquoi parce que quand
la mouvance de zarqawi prend le dessus
sur les autres factions insurrection
armée
l'idée c'est de comme je les dis donc de
proposer un projet politique
ce qui est aussi une réaction à d'autres
terrains du djihad passé les djihadistes
en irak considère qu' ils n'ont pas
finalement fini le travail ailleurs
qu'il s'agisse de l'afghanistan de la
bosnie de l'algérie
et qu'il ne faut pas se contenter d'une
lutte armée mais bien bel et bien fonder
un projet politique et c'est tout le
sens de cet état islamique qui est
proclamé la première fois le 15 octobre
2006 il ya eu des discussions
zarqawi par exemple s'opposait à
d'autres au sein de la mouvance qui
considérait au contraire qu'il fallait
rester sur la ligne al qaïda donc
internationaliste lutter contre les
occidentaux frapper l'ennemi lointain
alors que zarqaoui qui avait mis sur le
devant de la scène des irakiens donc
d'aider des locaux considéré qu'au
contraire il fallait territorialisée le
jihad et créer ce projet c'est
d'ailleurs tout le sens de l'état
islamique s'est on est bien dans dune
dans une lutte pour le contrôle du
territoire pour la récupération des
institutions en place au profit du
projet jihadiste d'ailleurs c'est ce
qu'ils ont fait quand ils ont pris
d'assaut vro soul on a grosso modo dit
aux fonctionnaires et aux personnels en
place il s'est simplement une alternance
politique vous n'êtes plus donc vous me
servez plus le gouvernement de bagdad
vous servez désormais l'état islamique
et à l'époque pourquoi je pense que le
contexte politique est important c'est
évidemment ces sunnites qui étaient
réprimés par bagdad par le premier
ministre maliki
finalement beaucoup se sont dit pourquoi
pas essayer l'option état islamique
finalement
les choses pour pourrait tourner à notre
avantage
dans la mesure où depuis dix ans nous
sommes nous nous sommes finalement
exposé à la répression du pouvoir
central
donc voilà les choses que les choses se
sont passées de cette manière
on a
quand je parle de gouvernement central
on a en fait des autorités à bagdad qui
contrôle un territoire finalement très
limité donc les choses ont été simples
aussi à mettre en oeuvre en terme de
conquête territoriale et l'état
islamique dont se revendiquent de ce
projet politique de restauration du
califat avec toute cette perspective
cette perspective donc salafistes qui
consiste à dire qu'il faut purifier la
communauté musulmane donc le premier
ennemi en réalité de ces salafistes ce
sont les chiites un l'iran qui ne sont
pas des musulmans en suisse assez sur le
terrain
l'irakien et sur les deux terrains
irakien et syrien ensuite viennent
évidemment les infidèles les mécréants
les alliés d'ailleurs de ce pouvoir
chiite en irak et au delà que sont les
occidentaux donc à commencer par
l'amérique
et puis par extension les européens
alors moi je n'étais pas encore une fois
surprise par cet assaut en je n'ai pas
de surprise pour ceux qui suivaient
cette affaire irakienne depuis un
certain temps encore une fois tout cela
est le fruit d'un long pourrissement et
pas un épiphénomène sur fois encore une
fois de d'absence de reconstruction et
d'institutions très faible il faut quand
même le dire
bagdad est une enclave ce n'est pas un
pouvoir qui est un état de droit un
pouvoir qui qui a en main le pays on le
voit aussi avec l'autonomie accrue des
kurdes qui aujourd'hui disposent de
leurs propres institutions de leur
propre région autonome et qui ne veulent
en fait plus entendre parler des
autorités centrales avec tous les
différends aussi sur la question
pétrolière et budgétaire et tout cela
dont vient rappeler la centralité
effectivement cette crise irakienne qui
a débuté en 2003 qu'on a voulu oublier
alors qu'il est aussi chassé de
l'actualité en partie par les
révolutions arabes de 2011 alors que en
réalité
l'expérience irakienne était déjà à
l'époque à mon avis
de d'enseignement serait qu'on s'est un
peu précipité pour chanter le printemps
arabe mais en réalité on pouvait
s'attendre à observer de nombreuses
difficultés dans les irakiens eux-mêmes
le disait en 2011
je me souviens c'est intéressant de voir
à quel point finalement les irakiens
déjà avait une distance par rapport à
tout cela en disant eh bien c'est
admirable parce que finalement ils sont
réussi à se défaire du joug de la
tyrannie par un soulèvement populaire
mais les difficultés seront nombreuses
et on le voit effectivement avec un
certain nombre d'autres configurations
alors maintenant sur les ramifications
de 2,7 de cette offensive comme je les
dis l'état islamique a beaucoup joué sur
les notions d'humiliation et de revanche
et leur d'ailleurs tous les symboles qui
sont liés à ces deux notions à ces deux
émotions sont présents à commencer par
la production si on s'intéresse à la
production audiovisuelle du groupe
vous constaterez que les otages qui ont
été atrocement décapitée par le groupe
était habillée de l'habit de guantanamo
donc on joue sur les symboles on a
humilié des musulmans à guantanamo et
bien finalement on vous rend la pareille
alors c'est une succession finalement
2-2 revanche opposé à ce qui a été perçu
comme une humiliation profond on le voit
encore aujourd'hui avec la dernière
vidéo qui est paru avec les deux otages
à poney
le gouvernement japonais promet 200
millions de dollars d aide non militaire
à la queue pour lutter contre le l'état
islamique la réponse de l'état islamique
ne s'est pas fait attendre
nous avons deux otages et nous réclamant
une rançon de deux millions de soles 2,5
millions de dollars alors on m'a demandé
est ce qu'ils ont besoin d'argent est ce
qu ils sont affaiblis à ce point là non
on est vraiment sur le terrain en
réalité symbolique où on renvoie
finalement les symboles de ce qui est
perçu comme une humiliation aux
oppresseurs on est vraiment sur ce
terrain là et pourquoi c'est important
parce que ça a des conséquences chez
nous dans les phénomènes de
radicalisation alors on l'a vu avec la
baie de guantanamo comme je les dis 2014
dix ans après falloudja le message est
très clair on ne vous a pas oubliés et
nous sommes de retour etc etc alors au
niveau régional comme je l'aï dit on à
une conquête territoriale mais on a
aussi un message finalement qui joue et
ça c'est très clair dans l'écho dans la
toute la communication qui est celle de
l'état islamique mais en réalité depuis
2006 s'est opposé à cette humiliation
irakienne arabe musulmane et là on peut
faire une longue généalogie de
l'humiliation en tout cas qui encore une
fois est un sentiment prévalant
aujourd'hui parmi ces peuples qui
appelle une revanche
alors ça fait des émules dans la région
le voir puisque on a quand même un
certain nombre de combattants qui
gravite vers l'irak et la syrie qui
trouve finalement un canal d'expression
a ses sentiments à ses frustrations
profondes et puis surtout et bien et ça
joue aussi
damman dans nos sociétés où ce message
qui touche à l'universel
alors on part évidemment d'un noeud
irakien sais rien mais à partir du
moment où la communication la propagande
est déplacée sur des émotions
universelles comme l'humiliation la
revanche l'idée de vengeance
et bien il ne fallait pas s'étonner
qu'un certain nombre de combattants
partent vers la syrie l'irak pourquoi
alors parce qu'on a aussi toute une
propagande extrêmement sophistiqué
écrite audiovisuelle je vais pas revenir
là dessus vous avez suivi en la crise de
2014 avec on a eu un saut qualitatif
clairement on a une offre entre
guillemets islamistes djihadistes qui
aujourd'hui est en anglais disponible en
anglais en français alors que l'ancienne
génération zarqaoui c'était plutôt des
discours en arabe donc de la filière
irakienne des buttes chaumont qui
finalement regroupé quelques dizaines de
personnes qui à l'époque d'ailleurs
symboliquement s'était radicalisé au
tour de de farid benyettou dans le 19e
qui allait s'entraîner dans le parc des
buttes chaumont
l'épisode tout de même qui a qui a fait
que chérif kouachi à l'époque décide
d'aller en syrie sous couvert
d'apprendre l'arabe et d'étudier l'islam
pour ensuite aller en irak combattre les
américains l'épisode quand même c'est
les tortures de l'armée américaine dans
la prison d'abou ghraïb en réalité ils
vont s'abreuver des photos alors je les
ai pas ici mais vous les regardez les
photos qui ont été révélés par le
journaliste américain seymour hersh dans
le new yorker
on voit ces détenus mise à nu humilié
voir déshumaniser les chiens lancé
contre eux et c'est bon c'est cet
épisode et c'est ces images qui à
l'époque vont abreuver alors on n'est
pas encore à au djihadisme 2.0 les
superproductions hollywoodiennes
à l'époque ces images qui vont
en fait qui vont qui vont qui vont
vraiment servir de point de départ de
l'arrêt de leurs indications de ce
groupe avec déjà pour miss pour message
on ne peut pas finalement laisser faire
ça ces irakiens ces musulmans c'est
aussi quelque part nos et évidemment ça
joue aussi sur les frustrations croivent
de ces jeunes qui se sentent en marge
qui se sentent humiliés pour diverses
raisons et qui vont finalement encore
une fois est bien décidé d'aller de tivo
exercer ce désir de revanche en essayant
de regagner la syrie l'irak et alors
pourquoi je pense que les dates sont
importantes parce que chérif kouachi
avaient toutes opportunités et occasion
d'agir avant et il n'est pas un hasard
qu après avoir échoué en 2005 a regagné
la syrie puisqu'il a été arrêté
ensuite il est juge et incarcéré mais en
fin 2005 finalement c'est l'échec de son
aventure et de ce qu'il voulait être une
aventure irakienne et ces attaques
interviennent dix ans après et je ne
pense pas que la dimension irakienne en
tout cas qui encore une fois est a été
au coeur de sa de sa radicalisation
alors il ya le passage par la prison etc
mais elle et elle est très importante
d'autant que depuis la fin 2014
depuis novembre on a une intensification
des opérations sur le terrain avec de
nombreuses paires tout de même dans les
rangs de l'état islamique
on a tout un contexte moyen-orientale
qui a finalement aussi qui est très
important à mon avis en arrière fond de
ces attaques il fallait frapper fort
alors les kwasi se revendiquent d'al
qaïda dans la péninsule arabique ou
libre coulibaly 8 l'état islamique mais
enfin je le dirais qu'il ya une
convergence en tout cas dans l'intérêt
de toute façon le frapper des frappes et
l'occident qui est un thème commun de la
nébuleuse dg de la nébuleuse djihadiste
au delà des disputes pour le leadership
entre ces groupes
mais tout cela était très symbolique et
alors je parler d'humiliation là là
l'émotion retombe un peu on commence
finalement à essayer de comprendre tous
les symboles de cette mythologie de
l'humiliation et ça c'est un papier que
je publie vendredi ou lundi dans
libération justement j'essaie de d2
décrypter un peu ses liens cette
interaction entre la situation à une
orientale et le parcours politique ou en
tout cas là la progression de ces
individus on a on retrouve dans leurs
paroles dedans dans leurs lectures dans
toute cette carrière jihadistes tous les
thèmes encore une fois de ce qui est
considéré comme une humiliation et qui
joue sur le ans quand on va sur le
terrain universal alors j'ai parlé de
l'irak
coulibaly lui s'est positionné sur la
palestine l'humiliation palestinian donc
en tuant des juifs ont venge la
palestine kwasi c'est finalement venger
la vengeance du prophète d insulte faite
au prophète par charlie hebdo et au delà
encore une fois je pense quand même
cette obsession irakienne qu'il l'a
rattrapé et qui a fait qu'à défaut de
pouvoir agir en irak et bien il l'a fait
en france dans son pays d'origine
et quand même soulignons aussi qu'il y
avait eu un certain nombre d'appels dans
les mois récents a contre la france
contre ses ressortissants avec plusieurs
vidéos qui a appelé à frapper la france
les français où qu'il se trouve donc de
toute façon il fallait faire un gros
coup ils l'ont fait et encore une fois
je crois qu'il faut quand même voilà
écouter ce qu'ils ont dit
c'est pas des décérébrés c'est des gens
qui se sont placés sur un terrain en
fait éminemment politique on a les
motions et ensuite on a le politique
avec un certain nombre de facteurs comme
je les dits favorables propres à notre
contexte national propres à ces
trajectoires individuelles qui sont des
trajectoires très précaire finalement
qui rendait ces individus vulnérables à
cette radicalisation et puis comme je
les dis le rôle d'internet
donc je finirai là dessus au moment où
l'on réfléchit finalement au moyen
d'actions et de réactions à cette à
cette radicalisation à ces menaces qui
pèsent sur la france je crois qu'il faut
se pencher sur les mots aussi plus
profond qui sont à l'origine de ces
actions
au delà du rpt france du renforcement
des dispositifs judiciaires d il ya tous
ces débats sur les fichiers etc
tout ça c'est très bien mais on ne
touche pas au coeur du problème est
encore une fois l'idée vraiment de ce
que de ce que de ce que je voulais
exposer ce soir c'est que mon avis est
que tant qu'on n'aura pas donc on ne
saisira pas en tout cas du problème
d'une moyenne orientale qui est à
l'origine de tout cela et ce n'est pas
nouveau enfin je parlais de l'irak comme
enfin le proche-orient et l'impasse
proche-orientale ça quand ça dure quand
même depuis très longtemps
tant qu'on ne se saisira pas aussi de
ces questions en termes de politique
étrangère et de nos choix de politique
étrangère de l'opportunité de nos
interventions de ce qu'on essaie de
servir dans cette région je ne crois pas
que ces mesures serviront finalement à
tahrir le potentiel de recrutement de
radicalisation de ces organisations qui
reste encore une fois très puissante sur
le terrain du moyen-orient et qui sont
perçues par un certain nombre de nos
concitoyens comme des organisations
révolutionnaires et surtout qui servent
une cause une cause juste
alors cela est choquant en soi mais
c'est pourtant et bien la manière dont
ces perçue par un certain nombre de
jeunes
enfin plus ou moins jeunes mais qui
décide d'aller en syrie et qui ont
vraiment l'impression de servir une
cause juste alors qu'elle est par
exemple
je trouve très intéressant aujourd'hui
qu'on se penche sur des sur la question
du discours et du récit finalement
alternatif qu'on peut proposer à ça
parce qu'on est vraiment dans une guerre
d'idées aussi une guerre profondément
idéologique au delà des mesures plus
concrètes qu'on peut mettre en oeuvre
voilà merci
on n'a pas lâché
il faut que ça marche pourtant quelqu'un
sait faire marcher ce truc
les deux boutons pékin merci ça marche
on va vous poser des questions
autant qu'on voudra vous demander comme
première question au four dans votre
dernier paragraphe la sueur tant qu'on
n'aura pas fait un certain nombre de
choses on n'y arrivera pas qu'est ce qui
vous paraît du point de vue opératoire
important dans les choses à faire
qu'est-ce qui est incontournable dans
des choses à faire qu'est-ce que si vous
aviez un conseiller barack obana l'un
des responsables politiques européens
est ce que vous diriez sur l'urgence et
l'incontournable pourra obtenir autant
que possible du patient que ce soit
certain mais c'est la règle du jeu de
l'interrogation un redressement possible
de la situation un rééquilibrage
possible de la situation là bas et pour
ça je veux dire beaucoup plus basses ici
je prends une pure question je vous
réponds d'envolées celle là d'abord de
m'échapper
alors oui parce que c'est vrai que c'est
il faut il faut dans l'urgence penser à
des mesures moi je pense qu'il ya des
choses très intéressantes qui sont qui
sont mises en oeuvre
à mon avis une des urgences c'est
internet de manière très concrète
l'idée finalement du déréférencement
d'un contrôle plus plus sérieux plus
large globale de la toile et me paraît
incontournable et je crois qu'on a
laissé les choses pourrir depuis trop
longtemps
alors évidemment ça touche à la liberté
d'expression aux libertés individuelles
mais enfin je crois qu'il ya un vrai
enjeu par rapport à internet
il ya un vrai enjeu qui finalement nous
sur lequel on aura un peu moins de prise
mais qui est tout aussi central c'est
évidemment l'enjeu au sein même du
sunnisme de la réaction à ces phénomènes
de radicalisation salafistes quelle
pourrait être la réaction qu'elle doit
être la réaction des autorités
religieuses sunnites
là je crois hélas malheureusement ce
n'est pas en une question qui nous
concerne directement ou sur laquelle on
aura beaucoup de prises mais il ya un
enjeu en tout cas dans le monde sunnite
aujourd'hui de répondre à cette à cette
dérive salafiste djihadiste incarnée
aujourd'hui par l'état islamique et
depuis plus longtemps par par al qaïda
ensuite alors sur le terrain français et
européens plus largement on a évidemment
comme je les lis un certain nombre de
facteurs à mon avis qui qui favorisent
cette radicalisation ou l'incidence que
ces messages en l'occurrence la
propagande jihadiste assure une partie
de notre jeunesse
et je dis bien la jeunesse parce que
c'est on avait une génération de
trentenaires dans les années 2000
aujourd'hui on est on voit des
adolescents voire des enfants qui
appelle au djihad donc c'est quand même
alors c'est le résultat d'une une
autoradicalisation c'est aussi dont la
vue avec la filière des buttes chaumont
des phénomènes de groupe mais c'est pas
des groupes donc très organisée donc
tout cela est difficile à anticiper
et puis évidemment ça touche à des
questions plus profondes liées a encore
une fois au pourrissement nos propres de
notre propre société entre guillemets si
je peux me permettre c'est peut-être un
peu dur comme terme mais je crois que on
peut débattre de l'opportunité de parler
d' apartheid m'enfin en tout cas la
question de l'intégration elle et elle
est l'intégration
enfin ne fait pas sens parlé d'
apartheid c'est peut-être un mot fort
mais moi j'ai trouvé tout de même que
c'était courageux de poser le terme
parce que on a un problème
voilà donc l'avenant territoriales et
puis surtout de 2,2 de citoyenneté qui
fait que certains français aujourd'hui
et bien qu'ils partent au jihad en syrie
finalement estime se réaliser davantage
sur le terrain syrien et parmi ces
organisations dans les rangs de ces
organisations djihadistes que dans leur
propre au pays donc la france je crois
qu'il faut poser les questions surtout
de 2005 s'est pas seulement le début de
ce groupe des buttes chaumont et c'est
aussi les émeutes finalement qu'on a
oublié
il ya dix ans qu'on a voulu finalement
mettre dans un coin mais qui à mon avis
aussi indirectement nous reviennent nous
explose à la face à travers ces actes
donc enfin il ya un certain nombre de
choses a pas posé sur la table à mon
avis sérieusement et puis au niveau du
moyen-orient pour vous répondre
on a pas on n'a pas de politique par
rapport à cette région il ya eu des
grandes annonces de fête en 2011 de
soutien à la transition démocratique on
voit bien c'est le silence total par
rapport à l'egypte et la reprise en main
autoritaire du pays qui ne qui n'est pas
une solution à d'ailleurs à moi c'est
que je donne mon opinion qui ne servira
et on le voit déjà que la frange dure
avec la reprise de l'activité de gea 10
dans le sinaï et puis tout ce que cela
implique parce qu'il faut quand même
dire aussi que ces groupes c'est le
résultat de l'autoritarisme dont on
s'est accommodé et qui continuera à
nourrir cette radicalisation dans les
pays dans les pays arabes et musulmans
alors quel est notre politique aussi à
l'égard de ces pays et quelles valeurs
qu'elle quels changements politiques
servant nous alors je crois qu'il faut
poser ces questions parce qu'on le voit
la faillite finalement de ces
transitions arabe et de ce changement
politique dans le monde arabe qui vire
au chaos elle nous concerne au premier
plan et je terminerai juste en disant
que ce qui moi j'ai des débats avec des
collègues il ya un certain nombre
d'autres personnes ce qui finalement
pense qu'on peut contenir tout cela nos
portes sans être affecté à un avis c'est
une illusion parce qu'enfin c'est une
stratégie comme une autre qui est
proposé finalement on fait du
containment et on laisse tout cela pour
r ça ne nous concerne pas je crois qu'il
faut sortir de l'illusion
ça nous concerne au premier plan et ça
continuera de nous concerner tant qu'on
ne se saisira pas de cette question et
qu'on n'aura pas une politique enfin pas
seulement éclairée mais aussi courageuse
ce qui nous a fait défaut dans les
dernières années bien merci
petite note en bas de page que j'essaie
de faire de manière modeste donc grand
affrontement entre deux des trois très
inégale famille de l'islam le sunnisme
d'un côté et le schisme de l'autre tout
sa revente au successeur du prophète
les partisans des uns et les partisans
des autres le sunnisme ses 85 % musulman
à peu près quelque chose comme simple de
zizou c'est 13% des musulmans il ya
troisième un petit groupe qui fait 2 %
le cynisme tout le monde sait bien que
c'est l'ami saoudite le qatar cetera le
gym le grand pays chiite c'est
évidemment l'iran et donc on a là un
immense affrontements et les mots
salafistes ou un pit et c'est les gens
qui sont partisans au sein de la
communauté sunnite du retour à l'islam
des origines connus ou rêver et de
l'imposition de la loi de cet islam sur
l'ensemble des organisations locales
régionales étatique
il ya des petites nuances ce que les uns
veulent occuper le pouvoir les autres
veulent plus qui est de pouvoir pour
avoir une ou mal c'est-à-dire une heure
une communauté mondiale de l'islam
vous accepte qui est des pays les autres
pannes mais je n'entre pas dans ce genre
de détails mais c'était simplement pour
expliciter les mots qu'ont utilisé
quelquefois dont on oublie ou connais
pas très bien le sens alors maintenant
c'est à vous les questions
oui il ya beaucoup de mains qui se
lèvent
on va commencer ma communion oui bonsoir
d'abord je remercie votre intervenantes
c'était tout à fait intéressant et voilà
que je suis docteur en sciences
politiques et je me suis intéressé à la
vision du terrorisme a parlé une
diplomate français est en fait sur votre
peau de sujets d'abord vous avez traité
le sujet à partir des émotions à partir
des deux des questions de sentiment en
fait en relations internationales donc
c'est quelque chose qui est tout à fait
porter puisque c'est là aussi quelque
chose qu'il faut prolonger dans ce type
d' analyse il faut aussi retenir en fait
la problématique même de l'existence de
l'état irakien est ce que au fond l'irak
est un pays qui peut encore exister en
soi est ce que le modèle de l'ordre
politique à l'occidentale c'est à dire
un état en irak at-il n'at-il pas failli
comme en syrie et puis dernière question
est ce qu'on ne pourrait pas non plus
régler ces questions de terrorisme dans
ces régions est chez nous peut-être avec
des solutions qui ne sont peut-être plus
opérable aujourd'hui mais comme par
exemple des reconnaissances également de
population proche orient comme en
palestine choses qu'on ne retrouve plus
d'ailleurs dans le drame dans les buzz
le programme des de nos diplomaties à
l'heure d'aujourd'hui reconnaissance
notamment des palestiniens se dire
qu'ils vont être vraie autonomie
politique reconnu l'indépendance
mais je sais que là dessus c'est pas
trés opérable aujourd'hui auquel j'ai
remis en jeu n'avait pas dit bien on va
alterner masculin-féminin su ça vous
ennuie pas ça mais alors oui je voudrais
te dis non non non non le nom le votre
nom c'est bien brahimi modem paris en
tout cas je vous remercie infiniment de
votre présentation qui était très
intéressante
je voudrais vous poser une question
concernant ce qu'il y aurait à faire
suite pour rebondir sur la question de
monsieur françois bayrou vous avez vous
mal gérée en egypte pour ne citer que
ces deux que ces deux pays
il a fallu faire des arrangements ou de
quelques années de terrorisme terrible
est ce que vous pensez qu en europe et
peut-être en france il va falloir penser
entre guillemets à une sorte
d'arrangement avec les islamistes
merci beaucoup oui bonsoir à tous fin du
caucus du 93 alors moi j'ai une question
que je me pose personne veut donner un
coup de poing dans le dans l'enceinte
bose sur la gauche là parce que il
semble qu'elle a un faux contact eu la
secoue un peu à les y voyant ces bons
alesi moi une question que je me pose
depuis quelques temps si je me demande
si au fond est ce que l'occident n'était
pas le principal responsable de la
situation du moyen-orient aujourd'hui du
fait de ces ingérences politiques
patients merci alors on va répondre à
ces trois là enfin répondre
alors sur la question de l'état irakien
c'est vrai que c'est le thème en vogue
finalement qui a été enfin qui est aussi
le résultat justement de cette offensive
de l'état islamique on a beaucoup
débattu à l'été dernier du legs
finalement des accords sykes picot
quel quel héritage finalement post
coloniale on a remis au goût du jour un
vieux thème des études moyennes
orientales et les devoirs qui frôle le
culturalisme à mon avis de
l'artificialité des états du
moyen-orient alors c'est vrai et en même
temps je pense qu'il faut se prémunir
d'un biais historiciste qu'ils
considéreraient finalement art et
réduire à néant 100 ans d'histoire
il y à une déconstruction c est à ces
états sont le fruit du colonialisme
enfin en l'occurrence pour la syrie et
l'irak eu des demandes à britanniques et
français et évidemment avec tous les
calculs qui étaient ceux à l'époque des
puissances coloniales et qui ont en
quelque sorte créé toutes pièces ces
états dans le même temps on avait tout
de même des sentiments d'appartenance
commune
et puis surtout là où il faut faire
attention dans la lecture qu'on en fait
c'est qu'il ya eu quand même une
réappropriation de ces constructions
nationales par les acteurs eux-mêmes
à commencer par les irakiens qui il faut
quand même le savoir dès 1920 et ça
c'est un épisode que jeu dont je parle
dans le livre ont lancé une grande
révolution à l'époque contre les
britanniques bien avant la proclamation
de l'état nation
irak informel qui interviendra un an
après en 1921 et à l'époque ils font
venir le roi fayçal de syrie qui a été
chassé par les français pour le mettre
sur le trône autour d'une monarchie
finalement assez fantoche mais qui
servira de régime politique à l'irak
jusqu'à l'indépendance et au delà
jusqu'à 58 en réalité et où le coup
d'état aux républicains il ya eu tout de
même une réappropriation ce cadre par
les nationalistes eux mêmes qui se sont
alors les panarabistes était dans la
négation finalement de ses frontières
toutes ces constructions les tendances
nationalistes plus local était plutôt
elle dans la réappropriation du legs
colonial à leur profit et au profit
justement de l'indépendance tout ça est
très complexe mais donc enfin l'idée
dont deux de ses éléments c'est de dire
il ya tout de même eu une histoire
politique tout de même eu un certain
nombre de encore une fois de deux
mouvements nationalistes de partis
politiques qui qui ont existé
l'irak et la syrie notamment n'ont pas
toujours été dans le chaos ont longtemps
été au contraire des modèles de
développement politique est à l'avant
garde d'un certain de cours en deux
parties dans le monde arabe
je pense que la faillite de l'état
irakien et l'état syrien dans la période
contemporaine et surtout à partir je
dirais des années 70 80 c'est surtout le
fruit de l'autoritarisme qui sous
couvert de nationalisme en tout cas si
je prends de lille le cas de l'irak sous
couvert d'un de la défense de la nation
saddam hussein s'est engagé dans une
déconstruction précisément de ce qui
était un embryon de versions en
réprimant les kurdes un an les génocides
ans il faut quand même dire les choses
en réprimant les chiites et en créant
finalement toute cette nébuleuse
d'opposants dès les années 70 80 qui qui
va qui va donc milité dès cette époque
pour une alternance en précipitant
l'irak dans une longue guerre de huit
ans contre l'iran dont on parle peu mais
qui a absolument ravagé la société
irakienne qui d'ailleurs déjà prépare à
l'époque cette montée en puissance des
salafistes
parce que le régime est totalement
décrédibilisée
et en 88 saddam hussein déclare victoire
la victoire
en réalité la société irakienne est
complètement exsangue la dette a éclaté
en fin c'était il ya plus d'un million
de morts c'est une catastrophe
convaincu de son de son pouvoir
il envahit le koweït guerre du golfe et
puis une décennie de sanctions la
décennie de l'embargo dont on parle peu
aussi que j'aborde dans le livre qui va
radicaliser cette déliquescence sociale
et politique en irak et qui va laisser
le champ libre déjà à l'époque aux
salafistes dont aboubakr al bagdadi le
fameux qui prêche dans une mosquée
salafistes à bagdad qui est alors
s'amuse à une joute un joug va jouer à
un jeu un peu ambigu un peu dangereux en
laissant finalement une marge de
manoeuvre un espace d'expression à ces
salafistes tout en édictant un certain
nombre de lignes rouges mais tout cela
est très complexe parce que ça sert
aussi en interne sa survie politique et
ses ressources au moment où il a perdu
la maîtrise d'une partie du territoire
parce qu'il faut quand même le dire le
régime s'est maintenu à travers une
sophistication très avancée de ces
outils de répression et le verrouillage
mais avec finalement la nécessité d'un
certain nombre de relais qui lui
permettait de tenir un territoire qui
lui échappe et eibar dadis c'est cette
génération embargo qui n'attend qu'une
chose
finalement c'est la chute de ce régime
pour pouvoir s'avancer
ce même bar daddy qui ensuite est bien
en contre zarqawi qui va militer avec
zarqaoui contre les américains se battre
et c'est et voilà en fait les racines du
problème donc encore une fois d'où
l'importance je pense de revenir sur
l'histoire mais je crois sincèrement que
les pouvoirs en place y compris donc
j'ai parlé de l'irak on peut parler de
la syrie évidemment le pouvoir syrien
ont contribué au premier plan à à
l'effondrement de ces états parce qu'en
réalité quand on parle d'état
c'était plus des institutions c'était
plus d d d d appareil d'état à
proprement dire c'étaient des partis et
à voir même en tout cas dans le cas de
l'irak
le règne d'un seul homme à la fin parce
que c'est pareil quand on parle et ça je
le
boc dans le livre à la fin de son de son
règne entre guillemets saddam hussein
c'était l'homme contre tous c'était le
règne d'un seul contre tous y compris
contre les premiers cercles du parti du
pouvoir on était tombé dans une paranoïa
absolue qui d'ailleurs il s'en est même
pris à ses propres fils à la fin donc
donc je crois qu'on a cette cette
expérience politique absolument atroce
aussi qui explique ces phénomènes donc
d'islamisation le fait que les
djihadistes on la voit finalement on la
porte ouverte
et puis c'est pareil comme je les dis je
reviens sur les éléments flot récent
maliki et tomber dans ce travers
autoritaire qui a directement permis
encore une fois à l'état islamique de
conquérir ces régions avec une
population sunnite qui était démobilisé
en 2000 2013 2014 qui a laissé faire
face à ce qui était considéré comme
inacceptable à savoir encore une fois ce
retour à l'autoritarisme tous azimuts
donc d'où le fait que et là je reviens à
votre question
la solution alors il ya l'aspect
militaire la confrontation d'ailleurs
quand même on n'en parle pas
actuellement la presse mais 2015 va être
l'année de la confrontation et des
opérations à mon avis les plus violentes
entre la coalition et l'état islamique
il ya une opération de grande ampleur
qui se prépare actuellement pour
reprendre mossoul
il ya eu les premiers les première
altercation entre les forces spéciales
canadiennes et les djihadistes dans les
derniers jours
donc en fait on n'en parle plus une
actualité chasse l'autre mais 2015 va
vraiment être très très très très
importante fondamentale pour l'évolution
de l'irak et
et par extension la syrie même si choses
sont plus complexes mais je terminerais
juste en disant cela il y a
fondamentalement un problème politique
au moyen-orient qui a trait à
l'autoritarisme et à sa rémanence qui a
trait évidemment aussi à la question
palestinienne il serait le arabe au sens
large qui n'est qu'il n'est pas résolu
et qui a été historiquement un d'état